we're just a few meters in front of the
presidential Palace where hundreds of
state employees are on in a protest here
at least 7,000 of them have already been
dismissed as part of the new president
have m's Bel tightening measures and
they are workers who had contracts that
were expiring and will now not be
renewed but there are many others who
fear losing their jobs the government
has actually shut down half of the
States Ministries there were 18 when
President M took office just over a
month ago now there are only nine left
people are saying here that this is just
the warmup for a national strike that
they're calling for for next week I'm
going to be speaking now to Gabrielle he
is one of the state employees to ask him
why or how many actually uh of the
people who are part of his Union are
afraid of losing their jobs
now
right now in the culture Ministry he
says there are at least 200 of them who
have lost their jobs
already these are the workers who take
care of museums cultural
centers and he says that if the law that
is right at this very moment being
discussed in Congress it's called the
omnius law which would it's at least
6003 33 articles to reduce the size of
the state he says there will be at least
20,000 more people who will lose their
jobs he's actually adding that if this
law is passed in the Congress there
would actually be as many as
32,000 uh fiscal workers including
hospitals doctors schools museums uh Etc
whose whose jobs are at risk and people
who would be out on the street as well
which I so as you say people here are
very very frightened of losing their
jobs but also of what's going to happen
the government in the meantime says it
will not give in it wants its law to be
approved they say it's the only way to
deal with this country's economic crisis
with its more than 200% inflation rate
the the strike has been called for next
week next Wednesday and we'll see how
many more argentines will answer that
call
alenis make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer